You've just worked with Sarah on a few modifications of our first program, and
I hope you found that you can make changes to the program without understanding
all of the bits and pieces. But still, it's a good idea to have a closer look
and know the lay of the land. First off, as I've said before, these two lines
are pretty routine pronouncements that you have to do with every program. And
most programmers don't think about it very much. You know, it's like when
you're in an airplane and the flight attendant says we're about to leave put
all your seats in your upright position, put the tray tables back. turn your
cellphones off. And most people just don't even pay much attention to those
things anymore. It's worth noting the word main here, that means it's the main
entry point into the program. It's worth noting the name of the program here,
and all the other things are kind of noise for us right now. Let's focus on the
important statement. Text like this. That's enclosed in quotation marks is
called a string. That's just a technical term for the text. This statement here
prints the string, in the exercise with Sarah you've seen that one can also
print numbers. If you put a number or a mathematical expression inside the
parentheses and that gets printed. System.out over here is technically called
an object. As you'll see in the next lesson, objects are things that do work
for us in a programming language. This particular object represents the
terminal window, the window in which a string or a number is printed when
println does its job. Finally, this part is called a method we'll talk much
more about methods in the next lesson. For right now, just think of it as an
instruction that's being executed. As you can tell from this part of the name,
the instruction is to print something on the terminal window. What's with the
ln back here? That says that it should also be prepared to make the next
printout appear over here. So if we first print ln Hello World, and then we
print three plus four plus five that printout will appear here on the next
line. Without the ln it doesn't make the next printout appear on a new line.
You'll practice working with both of these methods. With Sarah in just a
minute.